ces publicités sont direct efficace et
surtout omniprésent michael bloomberg
inonde les ondes dans l'espoir de rafler
la mise lors du super mardi le super
tuesday
dans deux semaines les 400 millions de
dollars déjà dépensés
quelques gouttes seulement de l'océan de
sa fortune personnelle de plus de 60
milliards de wons iphone ce procès dont
les années 80 que le milliardaire a
commencé à amasser son argent avec le
système d'information financière qui
porte son nom ni thèmes cruciaux groupe
de presse employé en 2018
quelques vingt mille personnes ayant
engrangé des revenus de 10 milliards sa
carrière politique commence en 2001
lorsqu'il décide de se présenter à la
mairie de new york sous la bannière
républicaine et lui juste après le 11
septembre il sera conservateur sur le
plan fiscal mis libéral sur des
questions sociales comme le mariage
homosexuel après deux mandats il
réussira même à faire changer la
constitution de la ville de new york
pour se présenter et gagner une
troisième fois
l'homme d'affaires philanthrope
financera ensuite des campagnes
démocrate il focalisera ses efforts sur
les changements climatiques et le
contrôle des armes à feu avant de se
lancer finalement dans la mêlée
démocrates pour 2020 vantant même sa
collaboration avec laraque obama meyong
entrust ou bamogo lille à ses
adversaires l'attendent de pied ferme
et puis certains démocrates ne lui
pardonne pas d'avoir soutenu la pratique
policière new yorkaise de stop and frisk
soit interpellé et fouillé
arbitrairement une tactique considérer
raciste qui visait surtout les minorités
par deux fois bluebird s'en est excusé
ces derniers jours sa montée incessante
dans les sondages fait remonter à la
surface
son passé d'homme d'affaires
intransigeant et ses propos
discriminatoires envers les femmes
mais cette ascension semble aussi
inquiéter son adversaire potentiel qui
lui a évidemment trouvé un sobriquet le
petit michael comme l'appelle trump en
référence à sa taille moyenne bloomberg
lui a déjà rendu la monnaie de sa pièce
quand on me demande si les américains
sont prêts à voir deux milliardaires new
yorkais se battre pour la maison blanche
il répond mais qui est l'autre mettant
en doute la fortune non documentée du
président américain pour la première
fois dans cette course
bloomberg descendra dans l'arène
politique au débat démocrate de mercredi
soir las vegas et personne ne lui fera
de cadeau
[Applaudissements]